how much space in it how many people do
you have here we have about 30 people
here in New York this office and offset
another floor that we expanded to
because we ran out of room with people
coming out of the out of the windows
here we let go it could have a
conversation this feels like a pretty
modest space from which to launch a
national campaign it was more modest
than this before this is actually like
it Nana feels plush yeah yeah this is
what furniture it's done yeah it was
more modest so in the beginning how many
people were here the beginning there
were four people maybe four or five yeah
and you yeah I might even include me but
again there's a year in you know early
2018 where no one was paying any
attention right so we knew we just had
to keep doing the work when you started
why did why did you feel it was possible
to run as long as you run at this point
we had a story to tell and you just want
to start beating the drum as soon as
possible I've been to Iowa New Hampshire
17 times each you know like some of the
people that I met there yeah I met a
year and a half ago and that for them
it's so exciting to see our campaign go
from the guy no one's ever heard of
we're just shows up in New Hampshire one
day ten now six in the polls
same thing in Iowa so we just knew we
were gonna help lay the groundwork for
the campaign what's your plan in Iowa
New Hampshire well the great thing is
that Iowa rewards passion and activism
because the caucus system is very high
commitment it's not just go pull a
ballot you have to want to beat your
neighbor isn't really make a case and
that's very much in line with people
that are trying to this campaign we get
a lot of passion and activism and the
yang guy what's the bar for you in Iowa
New Hampshire to stay in the race do you
think I I think that we need to exceed
expectations and I'm certain we will do
just that because the process set
relatively low expectations for us at
every level so when we finish among the
top candidates in Iowa New Hampshire
we're going to end up being the story
probably even more than some of the
folks that
I've been frontrunners the whole time
can you imagine the headlines nationwide
Andrew yang finishes second and IOR
Andrew yang finishes first in New
Hampshire obviously you've imagined it
yeah I just said it but then if you
imagine what the headlines will be
people will be like how did that happen
and then you'll see our campaign just
continue to grow as people wake up to
the possibility that we can do this for
ourselves
yeah if for some reason you were not to
get the nomination would you consider it
you're laughing
I like cordiality
would you consider a third-party
candidacy my job is to help get Donald
Trump out of office and I would do
nothing that would increase the odds of
him sticking around and I think a third
party candidacy would do just that
so that's not an option I will do
nothing that would help Donald Trump
remain in office if you don't prevail is
it enough that you brought the only idea
of the freedom dividend into the
conversation well I'm a problem solver
and so drawing attention to a problem is
helpful but solving the problem is much
much more helpful so I'm gonna be happy
when we pass the freedom dividend and
get this done if we pass the freedom
dividend and I'm not president I will
still be thrilled but I will not be
thrilled if it's like oh people are
talking about it I mean talk is cheap we
gotta take action what do you got up
here oh these are fun dated headlines
about the trajectory of the race so when
we started in early 2018 yeah I was a
longer than long shot how would you
describe yourself now I'd describe
myself as six and climbing and then here
we have I could run at least a semi
serious campaign that's an upgrade from
longer than long shot and then here is
he's a candidate with no diss squad like
no I know that a bigger yang mentum I
love it you know it's very catchy
we should make yang momentum a thing I'm
certainly made yang Yang a thing so you
can see there's an upward trajectory and
then you can imagine what the next
headlines will say what's like now it's
how's the entry gang on the debate stage
when senators and governors didn't make
it yeah and then after that it's how is
he top five and then they just it's
going to contain
nerdiest presidential campaign in
history yeah I might already have that
one wrapped up so you don't you don't
deny that headline no I mean I I've said
that I want to give my say of the Union
addresses with a PowerPoint deck to help
explain how we're doing by measurements
like life expectancy and mental health
and substance abuse levels and so I
think that probably makes me the
nerdiest campaign in history already is
enduring for real yeah I mean the answer
is in the article they actually say yes
he is for real they don't say that
that'd be bad journalism